[Musique]
Hong Kong était un endroit qui a vraiment contribué
à le façonner et en tant que personne, il a grandi
là-bas et il est revenu ici pour avoir une
carrière cinématographique
[Musique
] c'était un danseur incroyable
[Musique]
Bruce Lee a dit être comme nous aimons l'eau  et
quand la marche quand l'eau entre dans une tasse ça
devient la tasse
[Musique]
il vous savez était un père de famille aimant
qu'il était un bon ami pour les gens
j'étais un fan de la série évidemment Bruce
Lee est une grande partie de la raison pour laquelle
n'importe qui sait ce qu'est le frelon vert
[Musique]
qui a toujours eu mon bon héros non personne personne
ne peut le battre
il gagne toujours
[Musique]
une fête d'une association de scierie cétose
à Las Vegas de taro fossile un trio de batte
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
bien au cours de ces 40 années ont
commencé à se rendre compte qu'il y avait bien
plus à Bruce Lee que d'être simplement un
artiste martial ou un acteur et ils ont
découvert qu'il avait une philosophie profonde et
qu'il écrivait et qu'il influençait tant de
gens et  comment changer leur vie par
le travail qu'il a fait